hallo leute wiederum ein mann bekommt
eine neue folge wir testen da bin ich
wieder trendy und ich wollen heute
getränke machen und da kelly nicht da es
benutzen wir natürlich kein alkohol denn
hier ertragen uns auch ohne dafür machen
wir aber super coole drinks aus dem ober
watch koch ich habe nicht gedacht dass
ich extra für dieses video mir das buch
kaufen möchte zwingen habe ich die ebook
version wird wenn es geht bin ich ja
eher so keiner du bist so ein hype nerd
ja ich war riesenroboter verein am
anfang und dann ist sie jetzt weil ich
auch kein game mehr gemacht haben müssen
was anderes mehr auch wenn dann meine
freizeit umschwung aber ich habe schon
erheblich viel zeit ich muss lange
gestellt
[Musik]
es geht um die blizzcon die am ersten
elf stattfinden wird und zwar gibt es
dazu einen live stream um 19 uhr also
verpasst dem ich denn da gibt es wieder
ein großes happening richtig und
deswegen auch hier diese wunderbare
kampagne kann man also sagen weil es
schon vermehrt wir wissen nicht was
passiert viel mehr aber um das thema
watch geht das heißt diskutiert bisher
blizzcon dieses mal wieder blizzcon ich
finde es cool dass wir das machen können
auch gerade zusammen ja in der thematik
die wir beide jetzt machen und noch viel
geiler ist das aber watch ist und ich
habe mega tören auf halt irgendwas keine
ahnung ist es so ich habe vielleicht wir
dürfen nicht spekulieren ja genau ich
ein paar sachen gehört aber ich weiß
nicht genau
also ich hab richtig viele potenzielle
sachen gehört ich aber wirklich noch
keine ahnung deswegen kann ich mir das
natürlich dann auch entspannt rhein
heute abend wie ihr hoffentlich auch und
dann gibt es noch einen schönen aus
wirtschaft oder wieder ne ich gleich
schon los
richtig ja also ich würd ich würde
schnell einschalten
aber was machen wir denn jetzt weil du
hast nicht lange stehen unter dem titel
dritter täter tötete werkzeuge kompost
ich kenne die softdrinks wie wir heute
machen sind sehr spezielle drinks ich
habe glaube ich noch keinen davon
niemals probiert der erste model ist
limonade von der ist das lose you von
lucio suite krimi und pressing kult
gleis auf limonade ist just what would
you need is energy for abwickelt
open-air-konzert ja du lucius nämlich dj
in der welt von the watch deswegen hat
er nämlich seine ganzen waffen das auch
so ein sound blaster damit macht der
mann so schockwellen und sowas und mein
gott das finde ich hammer sehr unsere
limonade brauchen wir denn mit limette
zitrone backen water das verlangsamt das
ist echt einfach zuerst alliance im film
soul kitchen cat dennhardt brisanz auf
englisch übersetzt man bitte das
kochbuch auf deutsch ich bin ein leiser
übersetzt also alles allein in to medium
size of pizza wenn katrin haaf in use
the same container und jetzt drücke den
saft
gleich im container wie das fucking
discovery channel gerade was wir machen
alle weiter geht's gar das ganze video
auch mit einfachen sollten ganz so lange
so ich will das ist so nah wie kann man
uns jetzt nicht so um die menge an
daneben einen feeling die matte ist der
saft rik sagte
das genug zucker also wenn du mich
fragst haben wir content möchte drin und
dementsprechend würde ich sagen jahre
kondensmilch ist ja schon sehr süß ist
gibt's sogar tendenziell ja dann auf
jeden fall hätte der rhein schon oder
hast du einen entsafter h ja stimmt
ich hätte sie sonst mit der hand sehr
männlich ausgepresst jetzt plötzlich die
limette aus damit wir den saft erhalten
den limettensaft könnten wir jetzt dazu
[Musik]
sogar sich nach gelöst an er hat sich
dann auflöst und dann kondensmilch fiel
ein schuss in schuss so aber wir
brauchen ein sodass füllen wir jetzt mit
wasser auf und das wirkt jetzt wie eine
normale limonade
doch nein nein nein nein ja ich warte
ich bin voll gespannter
wir fügen die kondensmilch hinein doch
typischen fall cool aus ja vielleicht
noch mal hier rein machen und dann sieht
aus wie vanille sauce anschluss sowie
einer heavy ganz geil aber löst sich das
auch das museums gleich ne können sie so
kondensmilch jetzt drin
geil sowie zum anrühren ja klagen wegen
zweier seine farbe ändern komplett nötig
die gar nicht mal so scheiße audi sieht
sehr gut aus sogar im gegenzug eine
aufschneiden interessieren ja genau wie
[Applaus]
damals das ist so vor dir halten dann
sieht man es probieren geht über
studieren wie schmeckt die erste drink
bestimmten mir ganz sauber gar nicht mal
sauer
man schmeckt sehr deutlich am ende die
kondensmilch raus ist es halb bibel
erfrischend und dann kommt so eine kick
kondensmilch aber lecker frisch hat
hätte ich niemals gedacht ich dachte
wenn man eine limette mitmischt das ist
ja wirklich nur eigentlich so ein
bisschen für die farbgebung das ist halt
so ein bisschen anderen gern bekommt
aber halt übel frischen geile frische
limo und mal was anderes weil sie so
trüb ist und nicht so thema finde ich
geil brink nummer zwei der salafismus in
krimis rich spices einen anti doping
schmutzig und cremig mit einem
reichhaltigen gewürz fenster und einen
nussigen toppings jugendlich und
übersetzt und wer ist die person das ist
verraten wie und wann
bist du okay für unsere ziele brauchen
wir die stars ziehen vanille aroma und
sintra und ginger maisstärke und ein
bisschen freut sich ein bisschen viel
wollen wir werden jetzt in der
mikrowelle ein bisschen milch erwärmen
gute vollmilch und die kugel 1 37
kindern schmeckt ja jetzt schon ein
bisschen vor mich in unserem becher
erwärmt in der mikrowelle und müssen
dort jetzt ein bisschen weil sie stärker
einrühren
soll ich schon mal pistazien schnellen
musik sind auf dem bild ja gesehen dass
du gebraucht werden dann mach ich dir
die pest lcs klein in die milch macht
jetzt ein teelöffel maisstärke rein da
will ich da gut ergeben wir jetzt noch
hinzu
und irgendwann nur so oben drauf
gedrückt wird dann irgendwann auch ein
wasserleck und irgendwie das schon ein
richtiger wahr machen und so richtig von
herzen müsste ja so und so brutal lässt
und das macht mich richtig in
weihnachtsstimmung vor allem aus dieser
tasse auch weil alles mit vanille besser
schmeckt kommt jetzt noch wandel dazu
alter wie das im herbst kommt es gar
nicht sehen dass man so krass reagieren
jetzt hast du noch was raus gespritzt
ich weiß nicht ob ich das möchte so was
da drin ist was die milch zum leben
gebracht einmal in die mikrowelle
so jetzt bin ich gespannt 70 flüssig
muss das team gewonnen das ist pudding
schon sieht muss weil wenn ich jetzt mal
also testweise wenn wir mal was man
sieht es ja so ein bisschen bei euch
wenn wir jetzt hier aber mal so eine
piratengruppe könnte ist die pistazie
weg
[Musik]
wir haben uns entschieden die milch
jetzt nochmal mit den ganzen zutaten im
topf zu kochen
damit die richtig dickflüssig wird
[Musik]
riecht schon ganz geil aber ich verstehe
noch nicht ganz den unterschied zu
vanillepudding ja es ist es ist
problematisch und jetzt hier immer noch
eine große nummer zwei ein banner
vanille scholl schule oder auch den
salat heißt ok alles können hat mich nur
verhalf man richtig lecker mir fehlt
aber noch vanille aroma und ehrlich ich
hätte noch mehr vanille aroma amazon
findest du das nicht mal so nicht das
ganze paket dabei erhalten so eine in
einem möglichst wurde das muss nicht
alles lecker essen heiß noch aber ist
auf jeden fall nicht gefallen ich finds
auch lecker muss aber sagen der typ
deswegen haben natürlich davor die
lähmung hat mich schon nach gut unser
drittes getränk ist in der punch drunk
punch und du bist das ist du fest hier
kamen später ins game normalerweise man
hat immer so eine mission
da muss man sonnenwagen beschützen und
erfährt nur wenn du nah dran bist und da
war immer in einem wagen war die faust
drin von dumm bist weil du fährst waren
mehrere leute das immer so eine waffe
gewesen also eine künstliche haut
irgendwann ist er erzeugt
entgegengekommen und dann hat sich die
geschichte so verändert dass man das sie
dann rausgebrochen dass sie sich
sozusagen wieder aus dieser
hochsicherheits kabel geholt hat von
mitchell für den punch drunk punch
brauchen wir orangen zitronen limo
granatapfelsaft limettensaft zitrone
orange limette hallo gesagt und eis
schneide es jetzt eine gurkenscheiben
die limetten scheibe und eine
zitronenscheibe ja
die scheiben sind wenn ich das nicht
hoffen
dann würde ich dir den koch kanal
übergeben welche schaffe die vernünftig
ich bin für dieses getränk brauchen wir
ein glas voller eis und decke erst mal
ausreichend oder da wird lecker schmeckt
zitronen so da ein schuss limettensaft
und als topping granatapfel willst du
möchtest du da jetzt rein kippen ich
möchte dass ein kippen
[Musik]
das ist so richtig also jetzt mal
ernsthaft dadurch dass es jetzt so nach
unten gewandert ist das ist ein richtig
cooler alkoholfreier cocktail ja dass so
ein richtiges sommer denn auch lecker
schmecken lecker wer zuerst einmal
zusammen gleichzeitig hindu zuerst weil
ich hab noch gerade eben schon immer
geträumt vision für deco ein bisschen ja
sehen groß aber empfinde auch gut
irgendwie immer lecker zehn vw kombi mal
kurz in der nasenhöhle citrus zurück wo
ich für die nacht sehr sauber ferrari
ja ich glaube der limetten sagt es so
ein bisschen wirklich mal ein ganz gut
aber lecker wird unter gefallen
der ist bis heute man für intel weil das
ist halt macht schon mal ein bisschen
limo mäßig gewohnt auch voll frisch für
den sommer und noch mehr zieht gleich
mal vom ersten mehr überrascht mit
unserem vierten getränk radioactive
sogar float und wir machen den jetzt von
rot-rot ein tank
deswegen so dick dass nämlich ein
krimineller erst erst hankook ich weiß
aber auch dass kann ich dann weiß ich
genau hat mehr leben als andere und war
damals ziemlich europa hat also stärker
als so manch andere klasse weil er hat
so einen haken und damit kann ehrlich
von ganz weit her hinziehen das heißt
manchmal super tank wenn du halt da weil
du siehst ja welche gegner du hast ja
und wenn dann halt leute nur auf distanz
sind dann ist der hat perfekt weil er
dann halt umgehen kann so clarke
jemanden von der klippe oder vom
hausdach unterziehen können wir unsere
active ist so das lob brauchen wir
zitronensorbet und zitronenlimonade so
viele zutaten oder das echt sehr
überschaubar
zuerst kommt das zitronensorbet rein
links neben dir in der schokolade ist
auch so ein altes und zwei löffeln immer
so oder so bewegen laktose immer sorbet
immer so wie in cannes bekam nudeln
machen war man kann nur du machen kann
ohne die metal also zitrone limette oder
orangen so benehmen und ich dachte
zitronensorbet und wir machen das schon
viel zu lange von der leg numero dort
das macht dann 68
es gibt mir das einfach ein cooler
dessen echt radioactive aus aber das
könnte auch so aufnehmen doch ein
bisschen links damit dass radioaktiver
aussieht alter dieser schaum ist ja ein
mega krass geil oder lassen finale vor
das ist mein finale vor dass mich jemand
fragt von außen das ist meine final four
details darf man muss aber erst jüngst
zusammensein mit dem orange auf einmal
sonst glas genießen
lecker lecker also sorry limbo ist schon
geil aber limo es in der limo ist schon
anderes
geil wow das ist so aus und dem was man
normalerweise serviert krieg mit so
einem langen löffel noch drin weil wenn
man zu schnell trinkt hat man halt immer
noch bestimmte bestimmt oder bestimmt
das eis dass man einen löffel können
wollte ich das ab ich merke schon dass
ist genau dann denke wir sind einfach
zwei sachen die perfekt zusammen
funktionieren jemand einfach nicht
getrennten stellen muss wenn dann immer
zusammen ich hätte mir nicht gedacht
dass wir heute sondern auch rechtshänder
weiter also absoluter fan mit das wird
immer sondern wir sehen ja jetzt
gespannt was jetzt zum letzten gespannt
mega der ist einfach an die man sich
sehr einfach an dich angelehnt margot de
haan vorn
das ist diva diva ins mikro cameron die
sich ihren eigenen die besser ist es
alle anderen dem auf der ganzen welt
und die sitzt immerhin so eine musik
drin wenn sohnemann max ist auch ein
test ist cool die weiße weste gibt auch
viele cosplay man die wahl hat sich
durchgesetzt zum cosplay geworden die
einigung sieht aber auch hammer aus muss
man sagen für sein bunny hop tanz
brauchen wir eine limetten scheibe eine
kante lupe ihr wisst was gemeint der
wassermelone zitronensaft und wieder als
die wassermelone wird nun in die räte
geteilten sich schnell auf einmal ja und
wir brauchen den isaf ist genau jetzt
machst du so also warten ich versuch's
einmal und dann lasse drews dabei nehme
ich so
dann hast du ja mach mal so bissig wie
immer auch ein bisschen eis und können
uns abwechselnd mit ein paar sekunden
später eine situation cool aus überhaupt
noch tier
sie haben oben drauf sieht das erst zu
bauen hatte freut sich besonders dass
auch wie das aus aber nicht geklappt
fünf sekunden später und sieht aus wie
ein bisschen wie so ein fittes bin laden
versteckt hätten so ok wie kriegen wir
denn jetzt hier den wassermelonen saft
raus und ich weiß noch in den saft für
ihren aber eigentlich nur zu erreichen
wenn man jetzt so wie man mal wieder
welche rausbringen
guck mal das ist doch durch diese
aufbringen da rein schneiden kann das
sehr gut durch machen so und dann ja ja
ja ja wohl klappt wie du siehst wir
haben wir haben wassermelonen darf da du
denn jetzt die letzte zutat für heute
der letzte schritt für heute die alte
linie geblieben
das sieht auch wieder so hammer
ausgefragt und du sagst das geile
leistung aufkommen
oh mein gott ist so frisch aus hast du
deinen job vorbereitet o mein gott sieht
das cool aus darum macht man sich privat
nie so wirklich zum versiegen getränken
erwachenden die manchmal einfach in der
fuzo gucken uns zu sagen der blizzcon
stream an und machen uns bei unseren
tablet trink ich habe ich glaube ich
weiß welchen fällen hat der ist auch
lecker aber da finde ich sogar den
petrus citrus noch krasser als der ist
schon heftig lecker einfach nur also
beim jesus roth rock bei dieses lieber
wenn ich gut vielleicht ist es wieder
den vorteil dass sie aus korea kommt
oder sehen wir es ist auch ein papier
frisch dabei also bei mir dieses stück
eis dementsprechend ich fühle mich aber
auch so rostock zusammengezogen worden
wir haben uns heftig das cosplay costume
produzierte endlich für den nächste
gamescom dass selbst bis hin zu sehen
sollte
oh mein gott die nächste operation wirst
du dich als roth rock holt verkleiden
und ich als die war definitiv dann
machen wir uns so richtig wer kriegt das
bessere cosplay hin du heiliger ich bin
sehr gute muss schon aufpassen wir haben
euch hat das video gefallen ich bin mega
happy dass wir das gemacht haben noch
runter lassen würde ich sagen
und noch viel wichtiger blizzcon gucken
jetzt gleich denn was passiert und damit
euro schauen wir rein
sie machen was mit overweight das ist
die große frage was wollen sie uns sagen
was ist das große happening event um 19
uhr
schaut euch den stream an und dabei zum
video bei freddy abonniert diesen kanal
und wenn wir noch mal etwas wird mit
oder machen sondern ein cosplay was bin
sollen dann schreibt das bitte in die
kommentare das böse das sieht und sagt
hey könnt ihr bitte noch kurz flexibel
zusammen machen und sagen wir ja könnte
machen
ja danke und dann sagen wir cool
danke und dann sagen tschüss bis zum
nächsten mal ihr kleinod schief